I want to do something kind of
interesting this year I decided to send
some of our staff out to find the
absolutely best cosplay costume at this
year's comic-con okay
make the make it about you now there was
a lot of great stuff but nothing blew us
away quite like the costumes made and
worn by twin sisters Leslie and Natasha
Harpole they are 16 year old high school
students from Chula Vista they came to
comic-con dressed as their favorite
characters from The Walking Dead the fan
favorites Daryl Dixon and the iconic
villain negan ladies and gentlemen they
did an amazing job and we want to put
the spotlight on them for a second
please welcome these lovely young women
Leslie and Natasha
[Applause]
stunning fashion thank you so much these
are
I have to say Leslie Natasha these
outfits look fantastic
Thank You mr. O'Brien yeah yeah we felt
we found most of this stuff look good
you got it good will I see yeah yeah
yeah our dad is a cop so we borrowed
these weapons from the evidence oh
that's cool all right
now I meant to ask why do you have a
broom doesn't Darrell usually carry a
crossbow no no he doesn't know I mean
I've never seen this show I just like to
play dress-up it really is incredible
your skin looks so lifelike how did you
get your voices to sound exactly like
them it's really us it's super-easy we
studied the actors and we smoked a bunch
of cigars did hormone treatment for
about six months
and that's also how I grew this beer
feels yeah hormones are amazing yeah and
I made this hair out of old Barbie dolls
I forgot listen again this is very
impressive congratulations on all your
hard work ladies really thank you
we actually have to go we have we have a
sweet 16 birthday party we gotta get it
goodbye to both of you you guys are the
best
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you